the biggest AI delivery vehicle in
Microsoft is office 365 with the total
of 150 million the monthly active users
it's really a key part of everyday AI
you know we are working on so I'm going
to invite my colleague Rob to come up to
show you some cool features you know
what do we do with a are you off is Rob
Thank You Harry
hi everybody I'm Rob Howard I work in
the office product marketing team and
I'm really excited to be here today to
talk to you about the AI powered tools
we're adding to office to help people do
their best work the truth is we've
actually used AI in office for many
years you can think of features like
spellcheck and flash fill and
recommended charts that are a standard
part of the office you know and love but
with the advent of office 365 when we
took the cloud and deeply integrated it
with all the apps across office it
really accelerated our progress in AI
and as office 365 has grown it's become
one of our biggest vehicles for
delivering Microsoft AI technology to
real people and helping them get real
value out of it you'll see how we're
using that world data user data and
especially work data help save people
time help them focus on the things that
matter most to them even help them be
better writers and unlock hidden
insights in their data I'm going to
start off by showing you four of my
favorite a I powered features in office
these are features that I use every day
and you may have seen some of them but
like any good AI they've gotten better
as more and more people have used them
and I want to share with you the latest
and then I'm going to show you four new
ways we're bringing AI into office in
the coming months so let's get started
here in the latest version of PowerPoint
available as part of my office 365
subscription I'm working on a
presentation for the contoso mark 8
quadcopter and I will tell you I've
spent most of my career as an engineer
so actually actually building impactful
presentations takes more time and effort
than I'd like
and
just a second come back up so building
impactful presentations takes me a lot
of time and effort and frankly design
skills that I just don't have luckily
that's where designer comes in designer
lets me focus on the content of my
presentation and it takes care of
creating a beautiful representation of
my ideas so that's an as impactful as on
my audience as possible I'll show you
what I mean I'm gonna start here on the
title slide you can see it's a little
bit boring but I have a few images that
can spruce it up and I'm gonna drop them
into the slide and normally I'd start
rearranging them cropping them resizing
them to create a layout that I was happy
with but designer is always working for
me in the background and when I add that
content to the slide it automatically
pops up for me with advice on how to lay
them out and as I click through them
you'll see it's creating these beautiful
designs that are featuring the content
I've added to the slide and it seems
really simple because designer made it
that way there's actually a lot of
really incredible stuff going on here
things like salient region detection and
facial recognition and color analysis so
you'll see that even as its cropping and
resizing these images to build a
beautiful layout it understands that the
hand and the quadcopter are the central
point of the image and it keeps them at
the center even as it crops it or the
mobile phone and the remote control and
as it finds the darks and the
electronics and the mountains and the
blues and the sky and the water it's
able to echo those in the design of the
slide through color analysis and if I go
to the next slide you'll see I have a
pretty long image here with a lot going
on or a lot of different faces there's
this guy's yellowjacket here and it'd be
really easy as Cortana's pulling out a
square image from it for it to just take
the center or the left side but it's
actually able to recognize the one in
focus face in that image and as I page
through the designs that Cortana is
chosen for me you can see it's making
the hate the face the hero of that image
and I told you these are getting smarter
and one of the ways that designer is
getting smarter is it can deal with more
types of content so not just images but
now text as I go to the next slide
you'll see a set of development
milestones
now designers using natural language
processing to understand that this is
actually a timeline a series of months
and it's able to create from me a
beautiful representation of that
timeline that really makes the
milestones pop for my audience or I can
go to this next slide or I've got a
sequence of steps and designer
recognizes that as well and lets me
create a quick sequence diagram that
clearly outlines the flow and it's evil
even able to do things like pull out the
verbs from these steps and use them as a
quick header so I've seen how in a few
seconds I can use AI to help me create a
more impactful presentation in
PowerPoint now we're gonna switch into
word and see three more of my favorite a
I powered features already in office and
we're gonna start with another a I
powered assistant editor now editor goes
way beyond the spelling and grammar
checking that you're used to it actually
accounts
it actually takes into account machine
learning natural language processing an
extensive and ongoing input from human
linguists to actually make me a better
writer if I scroll down in this document
you'll see a bunch of examples of gold
dotted underlines and if I drill into
them you'll see that editor can catch
everything from overuse cliches like
think outside the box to jargon like
headhunting and even potential bias like
Youngblood and for each of these it not
only detects the problem but it suggests
a solution like maybe using new people
instead of Youngblood and if I'm
interested in learning more about that
recommendation I can drill in to see
more and get a lot of detail about its
recommendation as well as other examples
and I can customize the way that editor
works so if I really feel like I want to
hold on to my vague adjectives and my
Oxford commas I can do that in order to
preserve my personal style now we've
seen a couple of examples of how AI is
helping me create better work but AI can
also help me work more naturally along
the way one thing we see people do a lot
of is print off documents like these and
then take a pen and write comments in
the margin or mark them up with edits
and this sounds kind of silly but it
sort of makes sense it feels really
natural to use a pen and recent research
has shown us
actually using a pen activates your
brain more deeply than using a mouse and
keyboard
especially when absorbing information
but with AI and ink editor in word we
can actually make using a digital pen
and ink feel as natural as paper just
without all the printing and scanning so
I can do things like choose a red pen
and of course I can write in the margin
but this pen is actually better than a
real pen and that I can make edits with
it like striking through this sentence
and those edits are automatically
effected in the document I can even go
and change to a highlighter and ink
editor understands that I no longer want
to strike something out but add emphasis
to it and I can use gestures like a
circle or a scribble an ink editor
understands exactly what I intended so
now I've done my editing I actually want
to add a little bit more content to this
document you'll see I need to go get a
project milestone table and a forecast
chart and I know that these are things
my colleagues were working on in other
documents so normally what I do here is
I'd leave word I've gone to another tool
like Outlook or onedrive or share plain
to go and search for that information
once I finally found the document I
would go drill through it and find the
table that I needed or the chart I was
looking for I copy that out I come back
to word and I insert it that would
really break up the flow of my work but
with a new AI powered feature in Word
called tap I can directly within the
flow my work in the tool I'm already
using take advantage of all of my
organization's knowledge in order to
find the right content you'll see that I
can do things now like filter down to
specific content types so I'm looking
for this milestone table I can choose
tables and the first thing that comes up
or on the first list that come up is
this fabric ham case study for I know
the project milestones are and when I
drill in you'll see that it's not the
entire document it's actually breaking
down the specific elements that I might
want to reuse and here I see that
project milestone table that I can add
to my document with a single tap and
because it's still a full feature table
I can style it to look good in this
particular document now this cash flow
forecast chart didn't show up as one of
the top items well that's okay because
tap is actually tied into personalized
search powered by onedrive and
SharePoint so that when I type in
forecast I'm gonna get results that I
have access to and ones that are most
meaningful and relevant to me so you'll
see that the cash flow forecast is
actually the top item here I can drill
in and again find that chart add it to
my document and because it's a full
feature chart inside a word I can do
things like add a trendline
again without having to leave the flow
of my work so now I've shown you my four
favorite a I powered features already in
office I'm going to switch to what's
coming next
now we're actually gonna start inside of
Excel now if there's one thing we've
learned from our work in AI it's that
data is an incredibly valuable resource
and with hundreds of millions of people
using Excel there is a lot of data in
Excel spreadsheets and a lot of the data
looks like this it's a simple table but
there's a lot of columns teams category
type line items and I don't looking at
it get a sense of how this data works
what are the trends what are the ways
that these different categories and
columns affect the values and I could of
course use all the tools in Excel to go
create charts and pivot tables to
analyze it in a lot of different ways
but that would take me a lot of time
even as an Excel expert but with
insights which is coming to office
insiders this month I have an AI powered
assistant that will do all that legwork
for me so I can run insights on this
particular data set and really quickly
get a sense of how it works I can see
things like spend increases over time I
can see that if I break down this data
by type payroll has a significantly
higher spend than anything else and if I
drill into more insights I can see
deeper things like if I isolate just
stock compensation I can see a really
significant outlier and I might want to
drill into that further so I'm gonna hit
insert chart and insights will actually
automatically create a pivot table for
me in Excel tied to this data showing me
this exact insight I can mouse over here
and I can see the outlier occurred on
September 20
but I really want to understand the
source of that so I can use excels
functionality and pivot tables to break
it down by team and immediately I can
find that the engineering team is
responsible for that outlier and I can
go and investigate further so in just a
few seconds I was able to understand
this data set and find a few key
insights that I may want to investigate
further all right now we're gonna switch
gears to things that are truly
bleeding-edge and in fact so bleeding
edges that I'm gonna connect to a devs
machine in Dublin in order to show it to
you earlier we saw how in tap I can use
organizational knowledge in order to
more quickly access what I need and
incorporate it into my own work now
we're gonna see how word online can
connect to that in order to help you
understand your company better that
organizational knowledge can be a
barrier in addition to a help I know at
companies like Microsoft like probably
every large company it can sometimes
feel like we have our own language
especially when it comes to acronyms
when you move teams or work with
different groups it can be a barrier to
understanding and we're now connecting
word online deeply with the Microsoft
graph and the work knowledge that it has
so that when I open a document like this
word online can use that knowledge
pulling from the emails that I have
access to and the documents I have
access to to automatically identify
acronyms in the document and then within
the tool I'm already using identify them
for me so I can see AI n R means
artificial intelligence and research and
that it was found from my email or I can
see things like NPS means Net Promoter
Score and it's found it from files that
I have access to in my organization but
if I have one of these that I still
don't quite understand I cbpo means
business planning and operations but
what exactly is that I can even see
exactly the source of the information
and get an expert expert to understand
that business planning and operation is
actually a team at Microsoft all right
so now I'm gonna show you my last two
demos and they're both in Outlook
Outlook and recent features inside of
Outlook like focus inbox has done a lot
of work to help me spend less time
managing my inbox and more time focusing
on what matters to me and soon outlook
is going to show me Outlook is going to
help me do
within an email if I open up this email
here you'll see it's got a lot of text
but we're actually going to use natural
language processing to identify the
action items in this text automatically
so I've got a quick video that I can
show you on this one instead like I told
you this is bleeding edge stuff that's
coming soon oh there we go it actually
popped in so you can see that as I'm
looking through this email we're using
natural language processing on the email
to identify the action items in it
automatically so you can see the
underlines under did you see the update
the partner sent us and if I mouse over
one of these action items you can see
it's providing suggested responses and
these aren't canned responses it's not
just yes no maybe it said did you see
the update the partner sent us and the
responses are things like yeah I saw it
or no what was it so it's tailored to
the specific action item and when I say
no what was it Outlook automatically
creates a reply it quotes that action
item and it inserts my reply directly in
line and I can do that throughout the
entire email responding to each of these
action items so I can really quickly
make sure I'm covering all the action
items and respond to them even on the go
the last feature I want to show you is
an Outlook mobile and I have a feeling
that this feature was built exactly for
me anybody who works with you will tell
me that I am a perpetually late person I
have a tendency to schedule meetings
back to back I don't really take into
account how much time it will take me to
travel between them and it often happens
that by the time the outlook reminder
shows up to tell me I need to be there
in 15 minutes it is gonna take me way
too long to get across town
luckily Outlook and Cortana will soon
solve that problem for me you can see
that Cortana is giving me a notification
that I need to be leave by 505 to arrive
on time for dinner with friends and it's
telling me it's gonna take me 24 minutes
to get to the lake house based on my
current location and my current traffic
conditions so I know I'm not late and I
can even force touch into that
notification so I can see a route to the
destination I'm going to
and deep link into my favorite mapping
applications to get directions so I was
a quick lap around all of the AI infused
features in office but really that's
just a drop in the bucket we've been
hard at work
adding AI to office for years and there
are literally dozens of features that
are AI powered
you'll see things like quick starter and
researcher you'll see things like my
analytics ink to math ink to shape one
of my favorites math assistant if you
come over to the booth will tell you all
about the full story of office and AI so
thank you very much